[Music]
the pandemic has upended life across the
world
changing the way we operate day to day
facial recognition software is
experiencing disruptions as well
the wearing of face masks during the
coronavirus pandemic
has created a new challenge for the ai
software by hindering the ability of the
technology to read the human face
in a leaked government document homeland
security voiced its concern that wearing
masks
could obstruct facial recognition
software's ability to work
a study by the national institute of
standards and technology
stated that in march algorithms tested
had error rates between five and fifty
percent
in matching digitally applied face masks
with photos of the same
person without a mask in short
masks are putting a wrench in the
software's ability to perform accurately
but difficulties with the technology
haven't slowed market growth
in 2019 the global facial recognition
market was worth 3.5 billion dollars
and is expected to reach almost 10
billion dollars by 2025
according to market research even with
this growth
issues have continued surrounding the
software from biased databases to
reliance by law enforcement
facial recognition has been plagued with
issues that have created uncertainty
around the technology
a quick look at how it works facial
recognition software
learns to map a face via training
algorithms which store different images
within the database
these images can be collected through
the internet and public files
which include state issued ids and
mugshots
the mapping process captures and
compares facial feature images
and then matches the composited face to
determine the image's identity
the the kind of real surveillance risks
come from
the ability to cross-reference these
individual bits of data that
on their own don't seem like much if one
company
or one agency has someone's transaction
history and
a different company or agency has
someone's location history
on their own they tell you a lot less
about a person
than if you put them together in
addition to public concerns over
constant surveillance
this ai software has been riddled with
issues around ethics and lack of
regulation
another study by the national institute
of standards and technology
found that by using the database search
tool referred to as one-to-one matching
many facial recognition algorithms
falsely identified african american and
asian faces
10 to 100 times more than caucasian
faces
gender shades an mit project created by
computer scientist
joy bulemuni assessed facial recognition
data from leading technology companies
the study found significant racial and
gender bias
the data showed that the system's
accuracy detection rates were higher
among lighter skinned males
while companies performed the worst on
darker skinned females
there are a number of serious concerns
with facial recognition technology
this pours fuel on the fire of racist
policing that is already a huge problem
in our country and that
demonstrators are calling on our
governments
and society to fix right now it also
poses a direct threat to our privacy
and our ability to exercise our first
amendment rights
the uproar over facial recognition
ethics has had a snowball effect leading
more companies to object to the use of
the technology
over nearly a decade rite aid added
systems to 200 of its stores using
facial recognition software from a
company with ties to china
however recently rite aid deactivated
their use of the software
and shut the cameras off tech companies
are grappling with their own role in the
use and development of the software
[Music]
ibm recently released a statement that
they would no longer provide facial
recognition technology to police
departments
in ibm's statement they called on
policymakers to employ precision
regulation
that applies restrictions and oversight
amazon and microsoft followed suit and
declared their limiting law
enforcement's use of their facial
recognition software
all too often technology moves ahead of
what the law can do and so that's why
it's important that companies
like microsoft like amazon have
announced that they're not going to
allow police to use facial recognition
law enforcement relies heavily on the
technology to find suspects and support
evidence in criminal cases
sometimes the software points to the
right suspect
other times it can lead to a false
arrest
take the case of robert julian borchak
williams whose arrest for robbery was
prompted solely by facial recognition
but later dismissed according to
georgetown law's center on privacy and
technology
in 2016 one in two american adults is
included within the law enforcement's
facial recognition network
with few governing rules previously
established a recent bill was introduced
by congress to limit funding and the use
of facial recognition software by
government agencies
the lack of federal regulation of the
software has spurred increasing debate
and has caused cities and states to take
action
in 2019 san francisco became the first
city in the nation to block
law enforcement from using the software
san francisco is the hub
of technology innovation in the united
states
and they saw the warning signs loud and
clear and that ban has now been in place
for a year
and it's really kick-started a movement
across the united states
where you now have 13 cities that have
banned the government use of facial
recognition technology
we now have a ban proposed in the
federal congress
that would do the same for federal law
enforcement and
state law enforcement that received
federal funding
so when did millions of people consent
to having their facial features included
in these databases
and what does it mean for surveillance
and privacy
no one ever asked for this a lot of
these
changes weren't consented to they
weren't even decided upon with the
involvement of the people they were
going to affect
i think not only do we need kind of more
meaningful consent we also need ways
in general for the public to be involved
in
the design process for these
technologies and have
a meaningful voice in order to refuse
these technologies
while the public needs to be better
informed on facial recognition software
and its uses
activists journalists lawmakers and the
like are working to hold accountable
those involved with the technology for a
more ethical
digital future